[Music]
[Applause]
because we live in an age of unreality
we live in the age that Paul the Apostle
spoke about when men will believe
believe in delusions and falsehoods and
indeed nowadays if you don't believe in
the delusions and falsehoods then the
mainstream political and media Elites
will tell you that there's something
wrong with you when it's really they who
think they're
moths and the main moth that they think
they are is in regard to the Jihad
threat the global threat of Islamic
Jihad and the spread of sharia Islam law
the uh president of the United States
and the Secretary of State and the Prime
Minister of Great Britain and the
president of France and the chancellor
of Germany certainly and pretty much and
the pope every leader in the Western
World will tell you Islam is wonderful
Islam is peace Islam is tolerance Islam
has made a positive contribution to the
United States since its founding and one
thing must never do whenever Muslims
scream Allah abbar and kill people or
blow themselves up is think that this
has anything to do with
Islam and that the first Duty they all
seem to think they have is to make sure
whenever some Muslim does scream Akbar
and then blow himself up in a crowd of
infidels or shoot them down is the first
Duty that they have is to make sure that
we do not think anything negative about
Islam and so I think we are in the age
of unreality that would have shocked
Paul himself we are in an age of
unreality such that has never been seen
before an age in which unreality is
enforced and commanded at the highest
levels and if we don't believe it then
we are racist bigoted islamophobic
horrible people who are uh full of
hate now while all that is happening
there really are Muslims who are
screaming L Akbar and killing people and
hurting them just the other day in
Virginia there was a Muslim screaming
abbar who stabbed two people around the
same time within a day or so there was a
Muslim in Australia who was screaming
Akbar and he stabbed a woman to death
and the Australian police said this has
nothing to do with Islam you racist
bigoted islamophobe this has to do with
he was in love with her and she spurned
him and of course there are all sorts of
stories all throughout history of
spurned lovers turning to violence and
all sorts of cultures and so it's
superficially plausible until you read
on and you find out that when he was
arrested he was attacking the police
officers he must have they must have
spurned his advances as well and
he was known in the place where they
were staying in this hostel for being
violent and angry so apparently
everybody in the hostel had spurned his
advances and even more common than
unrequited love is mental
illness there are so many cases I could
spend the next hour going through each
one but it's they're all the same it's
it's as if they have a template and
whenever there's another Muslim
screaming Allah abbar and stabbing
people or driving into a crowd of
infidels with his car or shooting them
down and saying them I did this in the
name of Allah I did this because I'm a
Muslim I did this because I'm allied
with Isis whatever then they immediately
say this person had psychological
problems and so I think they they must
have a pad you know a pad with a form in
it and it says the attack on such a such
a date fill in the date and fill in the
place was not motivated by Islam but was
a manifestation of the persons the
perpetrators fill in the name Dee rooted
mental illness that had long been noted
by doctors and so I think you know the
diagnostic and statistic statistical
manual the DSM that is uh the guide book
for psychologists and psychiatrists the
DSM Manual of psychiatric disorders uh
there ought to be in the next Edition
a new category of mental illness called
Jihad
and that would actually though that
would involve their acknowledging
reality a bit too more strongly than
people really want to do these days and
so we know that's not going to happen
because it's too close to the truth and
the one thing we must not do is get
close to the truth and yet what this
does is open up a yawning gap of
cognitive dissonance a gap that makes
the grand Canyon looked like a super
highway there is nothing greater than
this cognitive dissonance Gap
the difference is this on the one hand
you have Islamic jihadis saying I'm
doing this because Islam says to kill or
to subjugate the infidels under the rule
of Islamic law or to convert them to
Islam and I am doing this so that I can
weaken Infidel governments or terrorize
the infidels in accord with the Quran
and it's all about Islam and all of our
governing authorities say the first
thing that we must not recognize about
this is that it has anything to do with
Islam there is that's an absolute
unprintable Gap and yet there is one way
to bridge this yawning Canyon of
cognitive dissonance and that is by
actually looking at what Islam is all
about and so uh we're going to do a
little Quran study tonight if you would
open your Quran first
you didn't bring
it I
wter
8:60 prepare against them what force you
can and horses tied at the frontier to
strike Terror in the enemies of Allah
and your
enemies same thing chapter 3 verse
[Music]
151 we will strike Terror
into the hearts of those who disbelieve
because they set up with Allah that for
which he has sent down no Authority and
their Abode is the
fire chter 8:12 when your lord revealed
to the angels I Am with You therefore
make firm those who believe I will
strike Terror into the hearts of those
who
disbelieve so that is oh and by the way
I will strike Terror into the hearts of
those who disbelieve
therefore strike off their heads and
strike off every fingertip of them you
don't hear too much about the fingertip
part but a few years back there was a
Muslim in New Jersey who murdered two he
was an Egyptian Muslim and he murdered
two Coptic Christians two Egyptian
Christians and he cut off their heads
and he cut off their
fingers and when the bodies were found
the newspaper account said he cut off
their heads and cut off their fingers so
so that it would be more difficult to
identify the
bodies and I thought no he cut off their
heads and cut off their fingers cuz the
Quran says inap 8:12 strike at the necks
and strike off their
fingertips but of course what could
possibly be Illuminating about Muslim
behavior in the Quran how could we
possibly think that the Quran the holy
book of Islam that they believe is the
perfect and unalterable word of the only
God
Allah that was delivered in perfect form
to the angel Gabriel to the prophet
Muhammad what could that possibly tell
us about what Muslims think come on get
with it you must be a
racist but anyway that just gave you
three verses about Terror and so we have
terrorism striking Terror into the
hearts of the unbelievers that is
strictly in accord with the dictates of
the Islamic holy book and so does any of
this have anything to do with Islam I
think those first three verses give us
the idea that maybe there is something
to do with maybe there is something here
and so let's go deeper there is an
entity in the world that the president
of the United States calls isil yes and
that everybody else in the world calls
Isis except for John KY who calls it
Dash do you know what Dash is Dash is
the Arabic letters for
isil what is isil the Islamic State of
Iraq and the lent what's the lant the
Eastern Mediterranean area Syria Lebanon
Jordan
Israel in Arabic the word for the Lan is
sham so you get Isis Isis or isil
isil on June 29th
2014 that group that called itself that
changed its name but they changed its
name to the Islamic
State instead of the Islamic State of
here and there they're just the Islamic
State now because they consider
themselves to be the caliphate the sole
legitimate government under Sunni
Islamic theology for Muslims worldwide
the only government to which Muslims owe
Allegiance and that's what they're
claiming to be and the global government
not only for non for Muslims but for
non-muslims as well
of course the president and John krey
and all the rest of them cannot call it
the Islamic State because that would
mean that they would have to utter the
word Islamic in connection with
something Islamic and they will never do
that and so they call it by its initials
and then if you were to ask them what do
those initials stand for Mr President
you know no reporters ever asking that
hey what does that isil stand for
Barack he would go run running into the
back because he would have to say
the state
of etc
etc Islamic anyway
uh is the Islamic State Islamic and does
it matter in the first place it matters
a great deal it matters a great deal
because the oldest adage of warfare is
you cannot defeat an enemy that you do
not understand
if the Islamic state is not Islamic we
need to know that and if it is Islamic
we need to know that as well because
whatever they are if they're methodists
or Baptists
Presbyterians probably
Presbyterian we need to know it because
we need to understand who they are what
they want to do how they intend to go
about accomplishing what they want and
How likely they are to accomplish it
cannot do that you cannot understand any
of that and therefore you cannot counter
it effectively unless you know what
they're all
about and so the president tells us that
the first thing that we have to remember
about the Islamic state is that it's not
Islamic and not a
state great okay but these are
statements of fact statements of fact
are susceptible to objective
verification or
reputation and so it is in this
case is the Islamic State a state well
they control a territory larger than
Great Britain they have currency they
have passports although no other country
will accept them they have a health care
System you got to have that in
state Isis care
and don't lose your
head
and they have various government
departments various administrative
districts all the accoutrements of a
state and they control a territory
larger than Great Britain they also have
subsidiary territories that are based on
uh in other countries controlled by
groups that have ad accepted their claim
to be the caliphate notably Libya
Nigeria the Philippines Indonesia Yemen
and
elsewhere there a state they're rather
large state in fact now are they
Islamic we must understand this question
as I explained or we ain't going to be
able to defeat this group so what do
they do one of the main things they do
of course is behead and they lovingly
film The beheadings and they show the
beheadings on the internet and the world
is horrified and says that was a big
mistake see now they're going to start
losing followers because people are
going to be repulsed by that and they're
not going to want to be associated with
such a group and I have seen the Learned
mainstream counterterror analysts who
know that Isis has nothing to do with
Islam say exactly that Isis is making a
big
mistake filming these beheadings and
showing them even Muslims are going to
be repulsed by this and they're going to
start losing right about
now and it never happens and why doesn't
it ever happen well let's go to the
Quran again CH 47:4 you remember that
verse probably from devotions so when
you meet in battle those who disbelieve
they then strike the
necks when you meet those who disbelieve
strike the necks I read out in battle
but that's actually not in the Arabic
when you just says when you meet those
who disbelieve strike the next how do
you strike the next well that's kind of
like
beheading and so the effect of that is
that when Muslims who read this book and
take it seriously and think it's the
perfect word of Allah see those
beheading videos they don't say oh how
repulsive I will not join this group and
besides John K is is they're not Islamic
they say hey finally somebody's doing
what's in the
Quran sign me
up and that's why they've had 30,000
young Muslims join them from 100
different countries around the
world and there's more I ask your
apologies in advance for the R-rated
portion of our program but it is coming
up so uh what we have in the other thing
that repulses people and horrifies
people is that Isis has seized many
kidnapped many yazidi and Christian
women and made them into sex slaves
you've heard about this no and people
think that's utterly barbaric how could
anybody think that that has anything to
do with one of the world's great
religions one of the three great
abrahamic faiths how could that possibly
be well let's go to the
book 4:3 marry such women as seem good
to you two or three or four well that's
reasonable
and I don't really think it and if you
fear that you will not do justice then
marry only one or what your right hands
possess what your right hands possess
what is that what do your right what is
what do your right hands possess chap 4:
24 is a long list because some people
have to be told of women that Muslims
are not to sleep with forbidden to you
are your mothers and your daughters I
mean some people have to be told this
chapter 4:23 but then chapter 4: 24 adds
and all married women except those who
your right hands
possess so we're starting to see what
these poor women are for chapter
23 which is right before 25
24 that's why I always have trouble 23
1-6 successful indeed are the Believers
who are humble in their prayers and who
keep aloof from what is vain and who are
givers of the poor tax and who guard
their private parts except before their
wives or Those whom their right hands
possess so it's beginning to become
clear what these poor women are for and
where do they come from we see from chap
33:50 oh Prophet surely we have made
lawful to you your wives whom you have
given their dowes and Those whom your
right hands possess Out Of Those whom
Allah has given to you as Spoils of
War so you have women who are captured
as Spoils of War in the context of a
battle between Muslims and non-muslims
and they're made into sex slaves it's
right in the Quran in multiple
places so is ISO un Islamic in doing
such a thing they are precisely
Islam and it's very clear you you know
people say well you know you really have
to read that in Arabic to understand it
as if kill them wherever you find them
which appears in the Quran three times
chap 2: 191 4:89 chapter
9:5 if somehow if you will learn Arabic
and you read it it really means give
them a
hug but nobody who translates it can
capture that
Nuance we live in an age of absurdity
and unreality and this is what were're
up against another thing that the
Islamic State did was when they came
into Christian areas in Iraq and Syria
they demanded that the Christians pay a
special tax from which the Muslims were
exempt and accept the hegemony of the
Muslims they had to show that they were
submitting to the Islamic Rule and to
accept various humiliating and
discriminatory regulations that denied
them basic
rights now surely the religion of Peace
of in tolerance wouldn't have such a
thing in it except it does chapter 9: 29
fight those who do not believe in Allah
or the last day and do not forbid what
Allah and his messenger have forbidden
and do not follow the religion of
truth even if they are of the people of
the book which is the quran's name for
primarily Jews and Christians there are
other groups that are people of the book
any zoroastrians here tonight and even
if they are of the people of the book
you have to fight them until they pay
the jiza which is tax with willing
submission and feel themselves
subdued and so if they are willingly
submitting and feeling themselves
subdued under Islamic law that make
takes form takes shape in that they
cannot build new churches or repair old
ones they have to pay the tax they have
to get off the sidewalk if a Muslim is
coming and always defer they cannot hold
authority over for Muslims so that
Christians in Pakistan I often see it uh
in news stories that Muslims call them
sweepers or street sweepers because they
only can hold the most menial jobs in
society that do not involve having
authority over anyone because to have
authority over a Muslim is not allowed
for a non-muslim under Islamic
law and so when the Islamic State
demanded the tax from the Christians or
their conversion to
Islam they were acting strictly in
accord with this principle and it's all
in the
Quran now one major reason why this
matters is because if this is all just
something that the Islamic State cooked
up in their
extremism then we can figure that the
Obama administration's brilliant program
called countering violent extremism will
take care of it and though get those
extremists and if you extremely love
peanut butter watch out because you're
on their list as well any extreme is to
be avoided this is really Socrates and
Aristotle in in in charge because we
avoid all extremes and are completely
moderate in every way but in reality
countering violent extremism is just a
way to dodge dealing with the Jihad
threat and to pretend that there is an
equivalent threat among faithful and
observant Christians and Jews and others
but if we acknowledge that these things
are indeed Islamic and that they have to
do with Islam well then see the Obama
Administration is in a lot of hot water
because they're bringing in hundreds of
thousands of Muslims every year and a
million since he's been president I
think more than that actually and it
could happen that the Muslims he's
bringing in may think that they need to
do these things as
well and then people might start to wake
up and this is why the age of of
unrealities is upon us people might
start to wake up and say wait a minute
why are you bringing in people among
whom there is an unknown and unknowable
number of Muslims who believe that it is
their responsibility before God to kill
us and or subjugate us under their
hegemony and deny us basic rights and to
institutionalize their law and impose
their law here which mandates
discrimination against women
discrimination against nonl Muslims
denies the freedom of speech denies the
freedom of conscience so that if a
Muslim decides he wants to leave Islam
that's it
death these things are inimical to the
US Constitution they're completely
contradictory to the US Constitution and
it's going it's a nothing but a recipe
for civil Strife to bring these people
in in large
numbers but of course he dismisses waves
away all concern about that as uh
religious one-upmanship that we don't
like them because they're not Christians
and as racism and bigotry and under
those rubrics which of course are the
primary sins as far as the mainstream
media goes he's able to wave away and
dismiss any concern about the violence
and the societal upal that he is
guaranteeing for our children and our
children's
children that's right and it is nothing
short of criminal if we had any decent
kind of opposition party he would
already have been brought up on charges
but he knew of course when he first
became president of the United States
that he had cart blanch and he could do
whatever he wanted because there was no
possible way that the United States of
America was going to impeach the first
black president and that the Republican
party was not going to DARE try because
it would make them look racist thank you
yes and of course the other aspect of
the age of unreality is Obama's
treatment of the Islamic Republic of
Iran which is the other side of the coin
Iran is what Isis wants to be when it
grows up and it is already an Islamic
State that enforces Islamic law it does
not go in for those flashy kind of jihad
Terror attacks which do terrify people
shooting up people in a nightclub
stabbing people on the street just
doesn't doesn't go for those kinds of
things what it does go for is something
much more subtle and more Insidious the
Canadian embassy from Iran the Canadian
EMB the Iranian Embassy in Canada I
should say excuse me in Ottawa was
actually shut down a few years ago by
the Harper government because it was
determined to be a center of Espionage
and subversion of course there is no
Iranian Embassy in Washington but there
are Iranian lobbying groups notably the
national Iranian American Council which
presents itself as a uh lobbying group
on the behalf of Iranian Americans and
against the Islamic Republic's regime
but in reality the few years back there
were a couple of Iranian dissidents who
said wait a minute the national Iranian
American council is actually a lobbying
group for the Iranian muls and on their
behalf and they were sued for Lial by
the national Iranian American Council
and they
lost and it was established in federal
court that the national Iranian American
Council really is a lobbying group for
the Iranian mulas and they have the ear
of the Obama Administration and they
were telling Obama administration
officials that it would be a great idea
to have this nuclear deal with the
Islamic Republic of Iran and so now we
have
it now that is really far more Insidious
and far more clever than random
stabbings on the street random stabbings
on the street have a great capacity to
strike Terror into the hearts of the
enemies of Allah I am not minimizing
them but the effect the potential
effects of the Iran deal and the
potential effects on the United States
of Iran's Global Network of terrorist
organizations which are operating in
Mexico and all through the southern
hemisphere could be far more
catastrophic in the long run than
anything that the Islamic State can
Inspire Lone Wolf Muslims to do
here and yet Barack Obama has enabled
them all the way along and actively lied
about it you may have heard of Ben rhods
nobody much had heard of Ben rhods until
Ben rhods made one of the most
astonishing political errors I've ever
seen anybody in power make he is a top
foreign policy adviser for Barack Obama
and maybe he just knew he was golden and
he couldn't lose and he may be right
about that because he hasn't lost
anything he's still top foreign policy
adviser for Barack Obama but what he did
was a few months ago he gave an
interview to the New York Times And the
reporter for the New York Times loved
him and was making him out to be a boy
Genius you know he's 37 he's on the rise
he's Barack Obama's top foreign policy
adviser who knows what lies in his
future maybe he will be president of the
United States himself or king or
Secretary General of the United Nations
or Pope or who knows what and maybe all
of them and since they're all
essentially the same now
and Ben rhs in an excess of self-
congratulation was boasting about how he
had sold the American people on the Iran
deal because he shaped the
administration's presentation of it and
he said that we got compliant reporters
to tell to report that the Iranian
regime was moderate and that Hassan Rani
the president of Iran was not like his
predecessor who you may recall mm akad
who was always saying incendiary things
and ruhan does not say incendiary things
but he is not by any stretch of the
imagination of moderate
but he was portrayed as such by Ben
roads on purpose to make the Americans
think that we were dealing with
reasonable people in Iran who wanted to
come to a peaceful Accord none of it was
true they knew it wasn't true but they
knew they had reporters in their pocket
and not Cub reporters and interns but
senior reporters respected reporters for
respected journals like the times like
CNN like the Washington Post all of them
who would report this and sell it and
hoodwink the American people into
swallowing this
deal
now the problem with this is what was
the end game what was the
objective the objective was that this
deal would be approved the deal even in
the best
interpretation in 10 years will allow
the Islamic Republic of Iran to get a
nuclear bomb this is a a government a
regime that its supreme leader the
Ayatollah K has said that isra will
cease to exist within 25 years well what
a coincidence they'll have a bomb in 10
maybe it'll be
sooner and has repeatedly said that they
will see the destruction of Israel and
they routinely every week at Friday
prayers they are mandated they order the
people in Iran to chant in the mosques
death to
America not only that but Iranian
official recently said that death to
America is not just a slogan death to
America is the foundational philosop opy
of our
regime they really mean it and they say
we welcome war with the United States
and they want it and they think with
Barack Obama being so weak they can have
it and win it not necessarily via a
direct military confrontation although
they don't seem to be shying away from
that you may have seen that just the
other day they were harassing a US Navy
warship in the Persian
Gulf and it was reported when they
captured the Navy uh the sailors a few
months ago and they were parading them
around as prisoners of war with their
hands behind their backs and their
uh blindfolds over their eyes they were
saying that it came out that there were
confrontations between the Iranian Navy
and the US Navy every day in the Persian
Gulf and Iranian officials routinely
boast if the Americans get out of line
if they cross the red lines we have
established for them and they were only
able to establish them because the Obama
Administration wants to pretend that the
Iranians are moderate and there's no
confrontation and so they shrink away
from any provocation no matter how
provoking and so they say if the
Americans cross the red lines we have
established for them we will take the
war to the Gulf of Mexico and attack
them there and you think oh well that's
an empty boast right well as it happens
Iran has a wholly owned and operated
subsidiary called healah the party of
Allah it's a Shiite Muslim group in
southern Lebanon and it's set to destroy
Israel that's its job that's what it
wants to do but his Bala is not just in
southern Israel they committed two
terrorist attacks in Argentina in the
1990s in Jewish centers killing very
many a great many people they were
behind the bombing of the US military
Barracks that killed 200 some people in
1983 in
Lebanon they are very active in the
triple Frontier region in South America
the the border between Brazil Paraguay
and Argentina which is kind of a lawless
area very remote and populated by a
large number of Shiite Muslims among
which are isbal they're active in
Venezuela which is of course another
Rogue State and above all they're active
in Mexico they have partnered with the
drug cartels in Mexico and if you keep
up with the news about the drug cartels
you will hear that they started
kidnapping and beheading people see
where did they learned that yeah they
learned it from hisbah meanwhile hisbah
is profiting from the drug
sales and it is an Unholy Alliance not
in order to control the drug trade in
northern Mexico but ultimately to get
here so when they say they're going to
take the war to the Gulf of Mexico it's
really not all that far-fetched with
their wholly owned and operated Terror
subsidiary right South of the Border
now but Barack Obama and Ben rhods tell
us it's a moderate regime because of
course this is the age of unreality
there's another thing about the Islamic
Republic of Iran the Islamic Republic of
Iran is Shiite Shiite Muslims are only
10 to 15% of all the Muslims worldwide
the other big group the 85 to 90% are
sunnis sunnis hate Shia and vice
versa and in Islam because it's not a
religion of Peace if you are a heretic
somebody with the wrong kind of beliefs
then you're under a death penalty so
sunnis because there's so many more of
them have killed and persecuted and
harassed Shia throughout Islamic
history now there is a very helpful
verse in the Quran that applies to
unbelievers but it also applies to
heretical Muslims or Muslims consider
heretical
and that is
3:28 let not the Believers take the
unbelievers for friends rather than
Believers okay if you're a Believer you
only make friends with Believers not
with the other guys let not the
Believers take the unbelievers for
friends rather than Believers whoever
does this has nothing to do with Allah
which is pretty serious unless you're
doing it to guard yourselves against
them so you can pretend to be the friend
of the unbelievers if you are protect
protecting yourself against them
thereby now the classic commentaries on
the Quran by Muslim Scholars that
Muslims consult when they want to know
what the Quran is talking
about they will tell you they quote as a
matter of fact I cir one of the foremost
commentators on the Quran whose works
are still read today he quotes one of
Muhammad's companions Muhammad's closest
disciples are called Companions and one
of the companions of Muhammad abuad said
this means we smile the faces of some
people but behind their backs we curse
them and we smile in their faces to
pretend to be their friends so that they
won't kill us but behind their backs we
curse them say Abu Allah maudi who was a
Pakistani politician he died in 1979 he
founded a major political party in
Pakistan that still exists jamaat islami
and he was also an Islamic scholar and
wrote a multivolume commentary on the
Quran and in it he wrote on the his
commentary on that verse that this means
that occasionally Muslims Under Pressure
May pretend to be the allies of their
enemies in order to protect themselves
against them which sounds to me a lot
like what Pakistan and turkey are doing
today but in regard to the Shia and the
sunnis it was the the Shia developed a
Doctrine called
taka which means concealment that they
would pretend to be sunnis to guard
themselves against the sunnis and not
get killed by them tea was necessary
because the sunnis were very Fierce at
some points very virent and violent and
they would kill the
Shia so the Shia protected themselves by
lying and pretending to be other than
Shia pretending to be Sunni now what
does this have to do with Iran
everything because Iran is 99% Shiite
and it is the foremost Shiite country in
the world as a matter of fact it's
almost the only Shiite country in the
world Iraq has a Shiite majority and it
has a Shiite government in Baghdad but
the northern part of Iraq is all sunnis
and they don't accept that government
that's where Isis is and Bahrain has a
Shiite majority and there's a large
Shiite minority in eastern Saudi Arabia
and in Pakistan and elsewhere but mostly
the Shia are a tiny minority and they're
persecuted by the sunnis so tea became
because this is a historical phenomenon
not just a modern one it became a very
important thing for the Shia such that
one of the foremost figures who
enunciated Shiite theology the sixth
Shiite Imam you may have heard of the
12th Imam but the sixth Imam Jafar ass
sadik he said tea is the center of our
religion and he who does not practice
tea does not have the
religion now that's a wild thing if
you're not lying then you're not a
Shiite
Muslim but they he said this because
they were under such pressure and so it
was absolutely necessary as far as he
saw it to lie and dissemble in order to
preserve the
community but Iran is run by Shiite
clerics who have dedicated their lives
to understanding and protecting and
communicating Shiite Islam do you think
it's remotely possible that they might
have been practicing teia in regard to
the Iranian nuclear
deal do you think that maybe when they
Javad zarif the uh foreign minister of
Iran was meeting with John kery that
maybe he was misleading him a little bit
about what the Iranian intentions were
do you think that a regime that is
dedicated to Shiite Islam and if Shiite
Islam has as its central element
deception that maybe there could be some
deception
involved and you're nodding how
racist
but that's the world we live in today
that if you acknowledge reality if you
put two and two together and make four
then you're obviously a racist because
everybody knows that two and two make
five that the Iranian regime is as
honest as the day is long that the
Islamic state has nothing to do with
Islam and that we can bring over these
migrants in large numbers and nothing
will happen except that we will March
together hand in hand singing John
Lennon's imagine and entering a glorious
Multicultural future
that's all that's going to
happen now what's really happening is
that George Soros one of the richest men
in the world and one of the most evil
and his minions his assistants his uh
his functionaries Barack Obama Hillary
Clinton and others they are dedicated to
an internationalist Marxist globalist
agenda and the globalist agenda goes
something like this the problem in the
world world is military economic and
political inequality in other words some
states are more powerful than others
richer than others stronger than
others and that's bad everybody ought to
be equal now in reality there is no
necessary reason why political military
and economic imbalances would cause
Strife there was a thing in history
called the PX Romana the Roman peace
when the Roman Empire had
absolute hegemony over most of Europe
much of North Africa and the great deal
of the Middle East and there was peace
there wasn't conflict because the Roman
Empire had so much more power military
politically and economically than any
other state in the region there was not
less TR more trouble there was less now
I am not advocating the return of the
Roman Empire although might not be a bad
idea and actually the Roman Empire is
upon us it's called the European Union
and it's very very bad in its current
iteration but
uh the the the equation between military
political and economic imbalance and
warfare is not necessarily so but it's
taken for granted as a Dogma on the left
it's
unquestionable and so Barack Obama was
seen during the 2008 campaign avidly
reading a book by fared Zakaria you know
on CNN the guy who was brought up for
plagiarism and nothing happened of
course because he's on the left so it's
okay
and he wrote a book or somebody wrote a
book that he copied uh called the post
American world and the post American
World Barack Obama was reading this book
he was deeply interested in it and you
could see when he was on the campaign
Trail going from car to airplane or
airplane to car and he has his finger in
the book on his place and he's really
absorbed in this book and that book says
that the problem in the world is that we
have one superpower that has political
military and economic strength greater
than that of the rest of the world so it
has to be leveled and if America were
drastically weakened militarily
politically and economically everything
would be wonderful and there would be
peace now don't you think that sounds
like the Obama program for the last
seven years and not only that but the
migrants are all part of this too
because the idea is to make every place
in America pretty much like every other
place in the world not just in America
and so if much of the world is poor
dirty squalid and dangerous then what
they want to do is make every place in
America poor dirty squalid and dangerous
and then there will be peace because
what will be the point of going to war
we're going to go over to war we're
going to go to war and Conquer that
other dirty squalled poor and dangerous
place why
bother so the idea is to destroy nation
states the idea is to destroy borders
the idea is to destroy nationalism to
shame us into not not into being afraid
to be proud of our country and wanting
to defend it and to equate being proud
of our country and wanting to defend it
and proud of our culture and our
civilization and our heritage and
wanting to defend it to equate that with
all these terrible things Nazism white
supremacism I wrote an article a few
years back for a a an essay collection a
book and mine was about multiculturalism
and was a bad idea and I said why it's a
bad idea essentially was I mean you got
to find 12 Pages ways to say this of
course to write an essay but essentially
it was this judeo-christian civilization
is good and it has been better for human
beings than other civilizations and
therefore multiculturalism is a step
back and a weakening of the things that
have made the world good and the
judeo-christian civilization has given
the world its universally accepted
Notions of Human Rights and human
dignity
essentially that and so uh Southern
Poverty Law Center or Media Matters or
one of those leftist groups they publish
an article say Robert Spencer goes
fullon white
[Music]
supremacist you know you got to wonder
about the honesty of people like that
I'm just not sure they're all that
honest but what they're trying to do is
shame us into thinking that to defend
ourselves is nativist is hateful is
bigoted is racist to want to defend our
culture Our Heritage our way of life is
evil when really obviously it is they
who are evil because they are visiting a
they're guaranteeing for our children
and our children's children a a a a
place a world that is far more dangerous
far more violent and far uglier than the
world in which we grew up and it did not
have to happen and it still really does
not have to happen although I think it's
going to be a hard road back the one
thing that we have on our side is the
truth and that is the greatest weapon of
all because the truth has a power far
beyond any power that we have right now
it looks very bad they control
everything they control the educational
system they control the educa the uh
entertainment industry so that our young
people are brought up thinking it's not
cool to love America it's not it's not
it's not with it to support uh anybody
but far-left socialists and that
socialism is The Happening thing as if
it hasn't already catastrophically
failed on half the globe and killed
upwards of 60 million people but anyway
Bernie Sanders is a Charming guy he
wouldn't kill 60 million people would he
well Hitler loved his dogss
anyway
the weapon of Truth is more powerful
than any hegemony they have because they
and they know it and that's why they
have to keep beating us over the head
with lies you know Geral the Nazi
propaganda Minister he said that the big
lie you get the big lie across by
constant repetition until people finally
believe it and I I remember that all the
time because I have a website
jihadwatch.org where I track Jihad
activity and uh publish news and
commentary on J Jihad activity in the US
and around the world every day and every
time there's a major Jihad attack a
Jihad massacre in which multip people
are
killed I see it happen again New York
Times CNN Washington Post they all come
out with articles explaining how Islam
is really a religion of peace all the
Muslims condemn this and this has
nothing to do with Islam anybody who
thinks otherwise is a racist bigoted
islamophobe every darn time and not only
that when Isis took the sex slaves and
Iran you through the sex slave verses in
the
Quran I saw an article in CNN by a
Muslim saying Muhammad would have
rejected this this is completely un
Islamic and so I was looking to see well
how is he going to explain these verses
about the captives of the right hand how
is he going to say that they have some
other meaning or they don't apply in the
Modern Age what's he going to do well
you know what he did he didn't even
mention them and he knew see he knew
that his his readers most people haven't
read the Quran and so they're not going
to know that these verses are in there
and they're and think here's the Muslims
saying that's un Islamic how nice we got
nothing to worry about this is just a
bunch of extremists and we all have our
extremists but we have the power of
truth and the truth has a power that is
far beyond anything they can do no
matter how much they beat us over the
head with this nonsense because the
truth is just reality and you can't keep
people from knowing reality as much as
this is the age of unreality all we have
to do is open our eyes and look at it
and so we see these guys screaming abbar
and stabbing and killing people every
day now no matter how many times they
tell us it's mental illness or
unrequited
love it's obvious it keeps happening why
is there this Global outbreak of mental
illness and unrequited
love and so I remember when I was a
young man uh during the Civil
War no when I was a young man in the
1980s and uh people were furious with
rald Reagan and I was too actually I was
a young leftist then I got better and
uh Ronald Reagan was being very
confrontational with the Soviet Union he
was calling it The Evil Empire and he
was saying he prophesied that it would
soon fall and people said what a fool
see he's just a scile actor and what
does he know we should have elected a
professional a real politician who knows
you know Jimmy Carter would have taken
care of
this
and uh
sorry and Ronald
Reagan said these things and people were
saying the Soviet Union Mr Reagan Soviet
Union is here to stay we have to find
some Accord and that was indeed the
conventional wisdom that was the state
department authorities wisdom the
experts in foreign policy's wisdom the
Soviet Union is here for the indefinite
future and we have to learn to live with
it and so we have to find an accord that
was the Nixon Ford Carter Dayton policy
that Reagan ended and everybody thought
what is this witless Cowboy doing we
have to have dayon it's the only way
into the future and he was right it was
just a few years later the Wall came
down and the Soviet Union collapsed he
understood that it could not withstand
the pressures he was putting it under
and that it was an edifice ultimately
built on lies and so all it needed was
enough pressure and it would collapse
and it did he saw it nobody else saw it
and nowadays I am confident that even
though the forces of evil and the forces
of deception and lies and the forces
that are mandating this unreality and
and beating us over the head with it
they have all the power and all the
control they have the politic the
political sphere they have the media
they have the educational system but all
they have are lies and lies ultimately
are going to collapse of their own
weight now I'm not guaranteeing it's
going to happen in 3 years like it did
in the middle of the ' 80s when we never
nobody ever saw it coming but Rd R but
it could happen in a 100 years but I
know that if we stand for the truth and
we refuse to back down and we refuse to
accept the lies and in our own sphere of
influences wherever we are we insist
that the truth be told and not accept
from our elected officials anything less
and not accept from those who were sworn
to protect us anything but
protection then the the lies will not
win out because the truth has a
compelling power beyond any
propaganda and so it could be if we put
up the pressure it could be very soon
that this collapses actually I'm quite
confident if I had come here a year ago
I would have been much gloomier than I
am tonight I am far more confident now
than I was a year ago today and that is
because of two things one is the brexit
vote and
that showed that people are fed up in
Britain and all the polls were saying oh
they're going to vote to remain in the
European Union but the people were fed
up and they were not going to vote for
remaining in the European Union while
the European Union is inundating them
with these Muslim migrants who were
going to destroy Britain and bring it to
a future of civil
strife and so they voted and also
there's the candidacy of Donald Trump
the candidacy of Donald Trump is is
extraordinary because like Ronald Reagan
he was not a career politician he's even
less of a career politician than Reagan
was because of course Reagan had a
successful two terms as governor of
California but Donald Trump represents a
deep threat to the political and media
Elites he does not tow the politically
correct line they've thought they had
him dead many many times throughout the
primary season and up to now they have
counted him out so many times because he
has violated politically correct
sensibilities and he said there's no
doubt he's borish and he says some
things he's rude says some things that I
wouldn't say because I'm a harmless
fellow
but the fact is that people are
responding to him because he's actually
speaking to their real concerns and
because he's an actual person who says
things that packaged processed Focus
grouped politicians don't say you know
we have had enough we've had it up to
here with politicians who read the poll
and then tell us in carefully rehearsed
tones what we want and you know I see
Hillary Clinton speaking it makes me
sick um because she's just speaking in
these cliche cliche after cliche
together we will March into the Future
come okay what does that mean dig into
your wallets yeah
and Donald Trump is actually speaking to
what people are really worried about he
says build the wall and and end Muslim
immigration and of course nowadays
they're trying to get him on saying he's
backtracking on both of those when I
think probably more likely is he's
trying to formulate ways in which they
could be practicably done but the point
is is that take the wall and well take
both actually that the Muslim
immigration thing rather and why does he
want to end Muslim immigration or put a
temporary moratorium on it or whatever
or a temporary moratorium on terror
supporting States immigration from them
Etc why because jihadis come in among
the immigrants that's obvious we have
seen that happen already in Paris it was
two refugees among the shooters who
killed 130 people in November 2015 in
San Bernardino one of the shooters had
passed five separate background checks
from five different US Agencies so he's
addressing a real
problem and he's called Hitler for it
now Hitler prevented the Jews from
immigrating so that he could kill them
Trump wants to prevent Muslims from
immigrating so they can kill
us you see how those things are not
actually quite the
same
and nobody who's been calling him Hitler
nobody has come up with any alternative
plan for keeping jihadis out Hillary
Clinton and Barack Obama and all the
rest of them would just rather American
get killed in Terror attacks then do
something politically incorrect as to
stop Muslim
immigration but the truth is against
them and reality is against them and so
they may win this election and they may
clamp down even more they're no friends
of the freedom of speech and so it's a
good thing I'm here now because this
time next year I could be in Hillary's
jail with that Mohammad
filmmaker but they will not be able to
stop the truth and it's going to get
them it never fails so I encourage you
to take heart but above all I encourage
you to work to fight for this this is a
war it's not a shooting war and I hope
it never becomes one but it is a war and
we are the soldiers the US Army is not
going to do this for us it's not a
shooting War we are in the war of the
information battle space and have to
fight for it and tell the truth insist
on the truth stand on the truth wherever
we are in whatever sphere that we have
and demand that we get it from the
people we support for political
positions and never ever back down or be
intimidated these people thrive on
intimidation and the great thing about
people who are bullies and Intimidators
is that all you have to do is stand up
for them and St your ground and then
they get
scared and so be of good heart we can
win this thing it's going to be
difficult but
we have the greatest foremost weapon on
our side and so ultimately we can't lose
it all thank you very
[Music]
much